Євгенія Емеральд - українська снайперка із позивним Жанна Дарк.
На військовому обліку жінка перебувала 10 років.
Із початком повномасштабного вторгнення вона добровільно пішла спочатку у тероборону,
а потім почала служити у полку спецпризначення.
Я про це подбала ще 10 років тому. Я спеціально закінчила військову кафедру, отримала звання, офіцерське посвідчення,
знаючи, що якщо, не дай Боже, буде війна - я зможу абсолютно законно, без проблем брати в ній участь.
Утім, Євгенія проти обов’язкового військового обліку для жінок.
Я відверто вам скажу: я до цього ставлюся негативно.
Бо це має бути реально добровільний вибір.
Все-таки основна роль жінки - це берегиня, це сім’я, це народження дітей.
Тобто не всім воювати. Це стосується і чоловіків. Не всім воювати на передовій.
Тому мене навіть ображало, я пам’ятаю, коли видавали повістки десь на пляжах чи в кафе.
Дискусії про військовий облік жінок точаться ще з минулого року.
У грудні міноборони України оновило перелік спеціальностей, який налічував понад 100 професій.
Через бурхливу критику список скоротили до 14-ти позицій.
Для представниць цих професій військовий облік мав стати обов'язковим з 1 жовтня.
Але після нової хвилі критики напередодні вступу закону в дію його відтермінували ще на рік.
Реалії цієї війни змінили дуже багато, і ми з вами побачили,
що багато жінок змушені сьогодні рятувати життя своїх дітей і вивозити їх за кордон.
І тут постає питання між двома речами: між тим, що, з одного боку, жінкам певних професій треба ставати на облік.
З іншого боку, жінка і, власне, чоловік, батьки, зобов’язані забезпечити право на життя своїй дитині і рятувати її.
І держава мусить гарантувати хоча б одного з батьків виїзним.
За словами Ганни Маляр, із 2014-го року жодна жінка в Україні не потрапила на фронт примусово.
У лавах Збройних сил нині працює понад 50 тисяч жінок. Із них 38 тисяч - безпосередньо служать.
Це один із найбільших показників серед країн-членів НАТО.
Генеральний штаб офіційно заявляв на одному із таких брифінгів, що станом на сьогодні
вони не потребують збільшення кількості жінок, які знаходяться на військовому обліку.
Наразі в ЗСУ є потреба лише у трьох спеціальностях - фахівцях із медицини, радіотехніки та харчових технологій.
Тому перелік професій можуть знову переглянути.
Міноборони і Генштаб виступає за те, щоб жінки цих спеціальностей могли ставати на військовий облік лише добровільно.
Аби закріпити це - профільний комітет у парламенті вже працює над відповідним законопроєктом.
Ми проговоримо про обов’язковість для деяких, певних категорій жінок, вірніше правильно не про жінок,
а про перелік спеціальностей ВОС – це військово-облікова спеціальність.
Але загальна думка про те, щоб більшість була або майже абсолютно, по всіх спеціальностях, для жінок добровільна.
Крім того, міноборони обіцяє, що всі жінки, навіть військовозобов’язані, зможуть безперешкодно виїжджати за кордон.
Досі на обліку стояли лише жінки, які пройшли військову кафедру, медики та жінки, які служили за контрактом.
Разом з тим юристи наголошують, що  військовий облік ще не означає мобілізацію.
Військовий облік - це те, що людина, особа, жінка/чоловік є на обліку у військкоматі,
у центрі комплектування і центр комплектування знає, що у них серед кандидатів бути мобілізованим
є така-то особа з такою-то професією, такого-то віку, з такими-то болячками.
І у випадку чого вони можуть, коли буде мобілізаційне завдання від Генштабу,
викликати цю людину повісткою і вже її мобілізувати та призвати до армії.
Та для українських жінок в армії немає майже нічого неможливого, вважає снайперка Жанна Дарк.
Війна не має статі. Жінка, як і чоловік, може вправна бути у будь-якій професії.
Тут вже більше можемо звертати увагу на якісь фізіологічні якості.
Наприклад, якщо жінка маленька, то їй буде досить важко бути кулеметницею, бо його треба тягати.
А якщо жінка така трошки збита, тобто сильна, взагалі без питань.
Чесно, я пишаюся нашими жінками. Жінки України довели, що ми не тільки борщ офігенно готуємо,
а ще й зі зброєю можемо добре розумітися.